a tumultuous week in Israel Ended as it
began in Tel Aviv and elsewhere with
mass protests against government plans
to overhaul the Judiciary
prime minister Benjamin Netanyahu and
his Coalition Partners from the far
right want to give politicians more
power to appoint Supreme Court judges
they say the court is elitist and
intervenes too much
the protests and a general strike
prompted Netanyahu to pause the
legislation he's promising to find a
compromise with opposition groups few
here believe him even President Biden
doesn't believe him nobody believes him
even his own Coalition doesn't believe
him
and we think that now it's the most
dangerous time of all and we're very
worried that
um
something we'll just uh they will stop
the negotiations just bring the law to
to vote the biggest fear
can think of
[Music]
it the protesters are from across the
political Spectrum including supporters
from netanyahu's liquid party
Netanyahu on trial for corruption
charges he denies says the overhaul is
needed to balance the branches of
government
on Sunday Benjamin Netanyahu will hold
his last cabinet meeting before the
start of the Jewish Passover holiday
they'll of course have seen these
protests but in that meeting there will
be a lot of pressure from netanyahu's
Far Right Coalition Partners to push on
with this attempt to overhaul Israel's
judiciary
Bernard Smith Al Jazeera Tel Aviv